you guys got a chance to train with Elon
uh to watch him train uh take steps on
his martial arts Journey what do you
think I think he's very strong much
stronger than the average man
he's got a lot of a lot of heart he's
very tough so I've always found that uh
by by Far and Away the most important
thing two people get into a clash of the
skill level trumps everything else in
terms of what's going to determine the
outcome the skill beats sorry skill
Beats
let's have to say other things aren't
relevant but skill is more relevant from
what I understand is proposed opponent
is almost two years of training
experience that's a big Advantage so it
will be an uphill battle I will say
hello about it that he deeply impressed
both George and myself with this overall
ability of philosophical subject and
very quickly is extremely intelligent
and sees what is the Crux of the problem
identifies what we be done but I also
believe that he's
probably one of the busiest human beings
on the planet that said uh these guys
doing martial arts training martial arts
is pretty pretty
yeah ultimately the deepest place
in society and
I think
there's two people who
have put themselves in a position where
they can create
greater benefits for Humanity than
almost anyone else in the world and so
there's a sense in which I wish they
would focus more on that and fighting
each other all right so one more round
this is for everything it's a submission
yes sir
for the greatest fighter of all time